SHOT.
AT THE END OF THE GAME, YOUR
MAIN MAN STEPPED IN AND MADE
THREE HUGE BASKETS WHEN THEY
NEEDED IT.
>> Brian: IF I TOLD YOU A HAWKS
FIRST ROUND DRAFT PICK WOULD
HAVE HAD A BIG IMPACT FROM THE
'18 DRAFT, YOU THOUGHT TRAE
YOUNG WOULD BE THAT GUY BUT IT
WAS KEVIN HUERTER WHO WAS ALSO A
FIRST ROUND IN THAT DRAFT.
19th PICK OVERALL.
TRAE YOUNG THE FAMOUS TRADE FROM
THE MAVERICKS TO THE HAWKS FOR
LUKA DONCIC AND A PICK THE NEXT
YEAR CAN CAM REDDISH.
THEY HAVE SUCH GREAT YOUNG
TALENT ALL PLAYING IN THE
PLAYOFFS FOR THE FIRST TIME AND
RISING TO THE CHALLENGE.
AS TRAE YOUNG IS LOOKING FOR HIS
DAD MAYBE ON THIS FATHER'S DAY?
HE SURE IS.
RAYFORD IS A PROUD PAPA RIGHT
THERE.
THAT IS HAPPY FATHER'S DAY IF
THERE EVER WAS ONE.
TRAE YOUNG WITH 21 POINTS, 1